for example a virgin she doesn't know
any much different depending on her
loyalties up with loyalty and I'm saying
that doesn't mean they'll have a happy
marriage going back to your specific
point which is why I point out men cheat
I'm not saying that every single one but
I think like as adults
but I'm saying it like as adults in a
conversation like yes they're going to
be exceptions but if you have an 80
chance isn't that better than a 30
chance and if you were a dude you picked
the you pick the the 80 chance and
second off the other problem is like a
lot of times what girls will do is
they'll give it to the last guys for
free and then try to like their use
Honda Civic and trying to require BMW
prices but you can't go back to being a
new BMW